hey this is a funny story this is not
like uh
mind-blowingly newsworthy but for some
reason i love this
fox news seems to increasingly be having
all sorts of technical problems where
people don't know that they're on the
air
their monitors go haywire they can't
hear things part of it might be
might be uh due to um
some sort of socially distanced
productions that are going on where
people are in different locations
during one of their shows they come back
from commercial and this guy greg
gutfeld
who's tweeted to me in the past started
singing about how
he has to go to the bathroom and host
juan williams starts a statement
gutfeld just sings over him that he has
to pee and people try to tell him we're
live right now we're on the air it
doesn't seem to matter
and then another host jesse waters makes
the most forced laugh
i've maybe ever heard to pretend that
this isn't completely humiliating take a
[Music]
look
now for one more thing i got a p i
got a p
you're on the air
[Music]
[Laughter]
great greg
jesse why aren't you saying you kicked
us off
that was so funny all right um i'll take
greg's slot until he has to come back
from the bathroom
i want everybody to watch fox news this
weekend i need you to start
what a time to be alive isn't it now i
actually have some thoughts
about this that might be a different
interpretation a few viewers have been
emailing me over the last couple of
weeks and they've been saying
sir no they said david i watch
this show on fox news with juan williams
and greg gutfeld
and i keep thinking that gutfeld
hates juan williams and is deliberately
uh
shunning him on air and for example they
sent me a clip from the other day when
juan williams was talking
and gutfeld was just looking down acting
like he was like on his phone and not
even listening to what williams was
saying
is it possible that in this clip gutfeld
could hear everything
fine and he knew he was on the air but
he just wanted to mess with william's
teleprompter read like
i have no idea if that's what happened
but i'm wondering
merely because so many viewers wrote to
me and said gutfeld treats williams
horribly on this show
to be honest this is the most
interesting thing that greg gutfeld has
ever said anywhere
i've never seen him be more compelling
and interesting than he was announcing
bodily functions that he needed to uh
participate
in uh his normal screeds are quite
boring and uninteresting and predictable
this was arguably the most coherent
moment greg gutfeld has ever had he
needs to urinate
he came across crystal clear i get what
he's saying i understand exactly what he
means
arguably the most that he's contributed
to a segment on fox news in years so
that's fox news continued technical
issues maybe
if you believe that that's what happened
one of our sponsors is
susman and han sussman and han has
everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
supplies
to stay safe during covid19 and sussman
and han
is the company that i've personally been
going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about
becoming a sponsor because their prices
are reasonable
ordering is simple everything ships
within 24 hours and they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated over 65
000 masks so far
to health care institutions shipping is
free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you
twenty percent off when you use the
coupon code
david